let's uh let's jump to the story from
pink news
because i think we're gonna see a lot of
people decide they don't want to be
associated with this group anymore in uh
what i would only describe as a
hilarious cell phone
pink news says anti-lgbtq
groomer slur banned on reddit in bid to
tackle hate speech your move twitter
okay let me just clarify uh
reddit did not ban the term groomer
but the fact that that's what they think
is happening and that the word groomer
itself is just describing the lgbtq
community is a ridiculous and hilarious
self-own they're calling themselves
groomers when that's not what what's
being implied and the evidence for this
is that there's also a smear against a
group called gays against groomers
and it is lgbtq people who are like we
don't like what these these these these
groomers are doing in our name that
sounds good it's great that sounds very
because groomer as a word refers to
people who are grooming kids that's bad
well news is trying to conflate
the entirety of the lgbtq community with
the groomers
and it's likely because in my opinion
there are there have been there's been
an attempt among uh pedos to infiltrate
and get the community to defend them and
it's starting to work they tried lgbt
that didn't work they tried map
didn't work
groomer all of a sudden now
these activists are coming out and
defending groomers saying hey stop
making fun of us
and it's like us what uh oh
love is love thing is not real there's
erotic love and then there's storg which
is love of family there's lots of
different kinds of and there's
pedophilia which is not about loving but
using children that's totally a
different type of love according to the
greeks than like your love of family
okay so i'm trying to logically figure
out why the left would do this the only
thing i can think of is it because there
are bad faith people
who are homophobic who are just starting
to use the word groomer as sort of
a new way just to call all gay people
groomers and again i still disagree i
was trying to figure out why would you
do this why would you want to associate
yourself with the term groomer generally
no
uh there are probably some people who
have yes but in terms of what grimmer
actually refers to it's like libs of tic
toc pointing out teachers are going
after kids right they're referring to
people secretly meeting with children
and telling these things
there may be some people who are saying
that's a groomer and it's just a general
blanket idea but the idea behind groomer
is specific to the individual targeting
a child this is exactly
so let me just say
the rule that reddit implemented was on
one subreddit and it said don't refer to
all gay people as groomers that was the
actual rule pink news then comes out and
says they've completely banned the word
it begins to slur against gay people and
it's like not all groomers are evil like
for instance this very neutral take the
groom when people get married there's
the man is now the groom he's being
groomed by the woman to be a father
we're not talking about semantics
parents groom their children to become
young adults to become good people good
parents do but that's now when people
are grooming them to do evil that's a
that's the kind of grooming that you
gotta watch out for ian is hashtag not
all groomers not all groomers except
groomer specifically is a verb that
refers to a specific concept and this
lexicon i understand yeah right so we
don't we don't need to describe the
differences between words like if i said
you know would you go for a run i'm not
talking about putting a floppy disk in a
computer i'm talking about going and
exercising and no one needs to
the conversation evolves keep that
little tidbit in the back your mind well
and this is exactly what was killing me
about the
you know the kid surgery when it comes
to to trans rights where this is the
same thing it's like guys is this the
hill we want to die on because now
people on the right are just seeing lgbt
groups
defending the word groomer and they're
going to go all right i don't want to be
associated with that i want i want you
to imagine this
there's a skeevy creepy looking dude
yeah standing outside of a playground
looking at children and licking his lips
and you go hey
you get out of here you you pedo and
then a bunch of gay people walk over and
stand next to him and go stop making fun
of us right and you go wait what right
what what
well that's what pink news just did and
it's like uh my concern was with that
guy targeting the kids but not y'all
yeah i don't like the amalgamation of
groups like a pedophilia is nothing to
do with bisexuality no gay no
transgender transgenderism has nothing
to do with gay at
all you can be a straight person that
transitions your gender you don't have
to be
so this this weird grouping together
maybe it's out of like a survival
instinct or something is i think it's
doing more damage to them 100 dude and
how many gay people
were probably livid when they saw this
probably that's why there's a group
called gays against groomers yeah and
one also they probably don't want to
speak out because it's like oh now am i
going to get in trouble for for speaking
out against groomers well they don't
even want to get involved right it's not
working no like they they're they're
starting an organization look great
against groomers
and the funny thing is they talk about
how there's like the lgb movement you
guys heard of this right yeah because so
there are people particularly in i think
the uk and they say
what does a woman liking a woman a man
liking a man or a man or woman liking
both have to do with being gender
dysphoric love it
so that's why there's been this lgb
movement that said that's totally
different from what we do get this a
transgender person who is a trans
lesbian that means they're biologically
male
transitioned to be a woman and then
marry a woman they do not need any
special laws made for them right they
could always in in 1990 those people
could have gotten married
gay people lesbians and bisexual people
had to actually get a legal right that's
why i understand fighting for you know
the gay marriage
t-q-i-a-s-2-p plus or whatever
don't
now in the instance a trans person was
biologically male and wanted to marry a
man because they were trans straight
they call it then you needed a special
law but that's only half
right or i shouldn't say half but that's
not the entirety of the trans community
in which case lgb all 100 of those
people needed
provisions to change in government so
they could get married the trans
community not completely queer community
not completely
ah intersex
nothing at all i mean the issue there is
there's a difference
and the cult
is trying to amalgamate as many groups
as possible like you ever see the image
of the muslim woman with the rainbow
hijab or whatever it's like a rainbow
flag behind her and i'm like that's
strange or there's a there was a um
i don't know if it was the l word or
some show they had a a lesbian muslim
woman and it created huge outrage in the
muslim community around the world
because they were like this is not
acceptable they're trying to take as
many different groups and put them under
one umbrella even when they don't like
each other so i think it was in
birmingham in the uk
muslims came out to protest
the uh the schools doing an lgbt
curriculum
and they were they were calling the
teachers like groomers and pedos and
stuff and saying we don't want our kids
learning this our kids are seven years
old they're too young for this and then
this guy goes i'm doing this for you i'm
doing this for you and they were like we
don't like you it's very strange when
they try and just lump everything
together should we put an m in there
lgbt mq
muslims they put black people in the
flesh black and brown people i remember
when i was i remembered i was super woke
and there'd be a story like that where
it was like muslims are fighting with
gay people and i was like i don't know
who's side to take without getting in
trouble oh this is terrible
yeah what do i do you make fun of
yourself that's probably that's what
comedians do i'm looking forward to
seeing the mca flag the muslim christian
atheist flag no it's the american
abrahamic alliance all inclusive yeah
come live at some point you got to
represent yourself yeah
forget about what color is because
you're just a human and be your best and
and speak your mind here yeah
there are many gay people who don't like
groomers that's right there should be so
they shouldn't be controversial you
maniacs well so this is why i say when
someone comes out and says that groomer
is a slur against all lgbtq people
that's the peta walking up to the like
okay let's do another analogy there's a
creepypedo guy looking at kids and look
at his lips and you say hey you peto you
get away from those kids and he walks
over to a group of gay people and goes
that guy's making fun of us right right
and then they go hey don't make fun of
us
i think an even more realistic analogy
is like when a teacher starts talking to
kids about things that aren't
appropriate to discuss with kids and
telling them to keep it a secret from
their parents and then online
the woke folk defend it yeah it's messed
up because they're using the badge of
teacher to hide behind because if they
did it at a public park they'd get
arrested especially
especially they were licking their lips
like all of tim's pedos were in his
analogies yeah i'm using
an extreme example of like talking about
anything let me
just if you go to one of these schools
and take the book genderqueer off the
bookshelf and then walk up to a child
open it and read it you're going to
prison yeah i no weird guys when we were
growing up
maybe not you taylor
but we just probably feared our teachers
we didn't know anything for all i knew
my english teacher lived in a shack like
they just had these haunting backstories
where you would kind of hear rumors
about like maybe where they lived if you
ever saw them out in public you would
just like run in the other direction at
no point would my like grizzled shop
teacher be like so i was laying next to
a man like he would have been arrested
he would have been arrested
um i i don't know about you but we
didn't have a whole lot of respect for
our teachers
i feared them dude yeah i mean i wasn't
scared of my teachers but i didn't know
much about their personal lives right
right that's true too
the only the only thing i knew about one
teacher was that she got married because
her name changed oh yeah or like a
teacher gets pregnant obviously you're
gonna know that yeah and we were like
hey look teacher's pregnant and then she
like stopped but she wasn't like you
want to know what position we did to
conceive no
no
no
i'm so little the ten-year-olds would go
what's a position just let me tell you
right no yeah let me draw it and then
don't tell your parents creepy dude yeah
do you think so
honestly your opinion do you think that
it is them being
legit groomer pedophile blah blah blah
or
do you think some of them are just
trying to
show how progressive they are and make
like a thing about it no some are
groomers and some are trying to
indoctrinate kids because they know they
don't have any of their own but also
regardless of the intention it has the
same effect oh yeah no no no neither
answer was correct they're both very bad
to be clear i'm just curious about what
you guys thought the left doesn't have
kids they have yours
so because they're not having kids
they're sterilizing their kids and
they're aborting their kids
this country is 20 30 years away from
being christian conservative hardcore
and it's really crazy because
this country went from like you know
obviously you go way back in time it's
much more traditionalist for obvious
reasons it's back in time but there was
rampant racism literal slavery and a lot
and dowries and things like that and
then over time these things change and
there's there's there's there's progress
and liberalism obama
then there used to be even with the
first amendment you couldn't swear yeah
even with the first amendment you
couldn't say naughty words yeah you
couldn't wear certain clothes and then
we became very liberal but then we
became so liberal that liberals started
killing their own children
went too far in one direction and that's
going to result in a flow back in the
other direction i don't think it's going
to get more conservative yeah i don't
think it's going to be christian though
because like what you're saying earlier
about like you you got excised from the
left but you didn't want to go full
right like you just wouldn't let
yourself like people aren't just gonna
say okay now i believe that cult like
some people they will some people might
but people in reality don't want to be
in a cult well and what's what's so
insidious about people on the left is
they they have will and have
said that i already have that i'm
already a right-wing grifter and
whatever and you guys have actually had
conversations with me and it's like no
man i just ask questions and i'm friends
with people who don't
share my exact world view and i'm pretty
happy i'll see like some people they're
like getting disenfranchised with
reality and you know when things can
start to go haywire like if you see the
stand you know people become religious
then they're like you know what
yeah now i believe in jesus and i'm like
wait hold on
this is like a lifelong
exploration you don't like get
traumatized and then all of a sudden now
you have a new religion you know so this
is actually interesting i pulled up the
stats and if you simplify the stats on
is the united states becoming more
christian they say no
because the country is 75 christian now
but by 2050 it'll be 63 percent and you
look at it it's actually a 20 million uh
individual increase so there will be a
massive increase in the number of
christians in this country however
there is going to be they say a larger
increase in non-christians there's going
to be about
90 or so million
new population of which only 20 million
are christians reducing the overall
percentage yeah where are those
non-christians coming from
if non-christians abort their kids
well we're seeing about a million people
per year coming from illegal immigration
or more so i wonder if that's the issue
however
many people coming from latin american
countries are also christians so i don't
understand their numbers
my
my belief and i don't know if it answers
your question is that it's religion's
getting fun now that we can see cosmic
microwave background and radiation we're
like whoa is god actually quantifiable
like this is an opportunity for a
generation to have a non-organized just
a kind of a belief structure about the
essence of reality it is much more fun
it is much more fun to where the
majority of people who have found god at
a later age it's not that i've met it's
not oh i went to jail or oh i was raised
going to church it's like well i did dmt
and you're like yeah there it is man
i think there's a lot of secular people
too who have similar values as
christians in some ways without
believing all the religious stuff yeah
our country is based on on the tenets of
christianity so it's through most people
in the society we talk about this quite
a bit that um the atheists of the 90s
2000 2010s don't realize they completely
operate on a christian moral framework
but it's because
they don't know anything about
christianity they think that their
morality is inherent to them because
another issue they've probably never
traveled to other countries that don't
have those moral frameworks
yeah i mean i
kind of what taylor was saying you know
i know for me
i think there are a lot of people in my
generation especially that you know
you'd say
i'm spiritual but not religious right
and so they saw what happened with the
catholic church or they were raised
religious and they rebelled against
their parents but they never really let
go of spirituality or they never became
a full-fledged atheist and one of the
things that i always sort of secretly
admired about conservatives is
when you looked at their words about
what they stood for it was like family
values god hard work and i was like
why are we against those things that's
good right that sounds great like why
was the left like what were our words it
was like weed
gentrification like it was just a bummer
right
and
now i think that because the left has
gone so far
uh cuckoo bananas i think that a lot of
people a lot of secular people who
you know ran out of richard dawkins
books to read i think a lot of people
are kind of craving that morality or
those family values that are
predominantly seen on the right or
within some kind of religious framework
i think that's normal too as you get
older
yeah is it because we're closer to death
and it's like hey
you know
dennis prager brought up a really great
point he says what does he call it cut
flower yeah caught flower culture
culture is what he called it that's what
he called it yeah so you have a flower
it's beautiful you cut it from its roots
and it stays beautiful but eventually
withers and dies
and that's
what i think is happening you had a
period where well i mean for a long time
this country was like 100 christian
basically right right and that had a lot
of bad things about it um you know
culturally there was a lot of uh is
rigid very rigid like you know george
carlin getting arrested for swearing and
stuff like that right
then eventually you get some atheism but
it's still based on moral values from
christians so they start saying things
like i don't think god's real but i
still agree the innocent should not be
prosecuted for crimes they may not have
committed unless it's proven beyond a
reasonable doubt
and then you're like where does that
come from and they don't know right
because they didn't study the bible and
they didn't learn about the history of
blackstone's formulation and where it
came from and all the stuff and then you
realize like hey wait a minute china
doesn't have that like in china they
just lock you up and they torture you if
you oppose the government now that's
communism
you know that's not the traditional
chinese values but the point is those
people are not raised with the same
moral values we have
interesting
now we're starting to see what happens
when the atheist children of parents who
don't know where their values come from
raise children
and they don't know how to trade to
bring those values to those kids and
those kids are you know the current
millennial generation
well my parents did it right man where i
wasn't raised religious
my dad is a jew
and my mom is
christian-ish and we didn't go to church
and we didn't go to synagogue but we
celebrated passover and hanukkah and
christmas and you know they would always
tell us about our
our relatives and our ancestors and all
this stuff but they
believed in god and believed in the
framework of just being a good person
and so they didn't raise us
anti-religious you know what i mean like
we didn't go to church we didn't get
burnt out on that but it was still hey
be a good person we're not alone we
don't know but we're not alone and i
think that's why i never could go that
like full throttle hateful atheist who
just spends all day on you know reddit
calling religious people dumb i think
that's why i still always
sought out
something because you don't know you
can't be if you say you're an atheist
you you're just as
fundamentalist like
even when i thought i was an atheist i
called myself agnostic because i don't
know if i called myself an atheist and
god came crashing down to the ceiling
and was like i'm real i wouldn't be like
no i've read sam harris i'd be like all
right man i guess i was wrong which
makes me agnostic what's funny is um
looking at these polls about the future
of christianity
i wonder how they make the determination
because you can't predict culture if you
could make your investments now you'll
be rich
i think they underestimate the cultural
shift
that dmt particularly will bring a bring
upon atheists it's possible for real
dude christianity is going to reform
into like because the idea of christ is
like the anointed one and jesus just
happened to be the christ of that time
he was anointed by god but we can all be
anointed by god i believe that anyway
that it's flowing through us all yeah
media well i mean i uh i made that dmt
thing as kind of a joke but am i allowed
to talk about uh me doing drugs on
youtube hell yeah well we talk about dmt
all the time we just don't have you're
not supposed to do drugs on youtube i
had a terrible experience where i found
god um i
no i i uh
by
during covid or right before lockdown
my
cat died and my girlfriend left in the
same week and it was awful and i was
infinitely more upset about the cat than
the girl because he was the best oh and
she would like see me she would see me
crying and be like don't worry we'll
still be friends and i was like oh i'm
crying about the cat but i'd be like
yeah yeah we'll still be friends
and so over valentine's day it was my
first valentine's day i'd ever spent
alone i was like i'm gonna take
mushrooms for the first time since high
school and everyone was like that is the
worst idea i've ever heard
and they're like timing you're gonna be
alone on valentine's day and guess what
i wasn't alone i was with everyone and
god and i for the longest time i
considered myself agnostic i considered
but
people have these experiences people on
their deathbed again when they are given
by medical professionals there are
doctors who do this um people on their
deathbed who are so scared of death
they are with a doctor with a
professional given psilocybin
and they no longer fear death they do
see something it does open something up
in you um what if like right before
people died we just blasted them with
dmt would be the best like like when you
they say when you die
your brain releases dmt right like a ton
of it what if they were just like
tenfold baby intravenous drip i'm
putting that in my will let's go yeah
we're all putting that in our wheels yo
i think you should i want that in my
employment contract here right i think
when you're like certifiably like about
to die you should be able to just like
yeah right to choose i think is that
what they call well look they're right
to try to try is like if you're dying
you can try a drug i'm saying no like if
the doctor's like you got an hour left
you should be able to be like i can have
any drug i want exactly yeah it's like a
prisoner's last meal before execution
they just give you a list which is like
acid psilocybin dmt mescaline so yeah
man and you decide like weeks before
like way if the moment comes yeah and
then i turn the light green by like uh
whatever i'm able to do you could do it
like an ice cream shop you could be like
can i do half dmt half psilocybin they
would be like yeah buddy
it's your special day party
and they monitor your heart rate yep
monitor your brain waves or whatever and
they're like well you someone's like
give me the full blast of all of you
know of acid dmt and cells give me the
joe rogan treatment that's what they've
called it
i saw
a broken punch alexandria cortez uh
tweeted out last week that she had
somehow included in the ndaa uh
something about legalizing psilocybin
and mdma for pay for people to like
patients and stuff yeah and i got mixed
with you
yeah it's on twitter at least last week
i think that is very healthy you know
more and more popular i mean look man
these politicians the second they see
money is behind it you know tim ferriss
a lot of guys like that in sort of like
the tech self-help podcast world have
done a great job about talking about
psilocybin for ptsd for depression for
all this stuff and there's a new
michael pollan has been great there's a
new documentary on netflix that comes
out this month all about the medicinal
uses of psilocybin by michael pollan who
his book is called i think it was the
number one bestseller how to change your
mind was his book all about um
psychedelics and there is going to be a
real movement for
once politicians see that there is money
behind it we saw it with weed
legalization suddenly they're all going
to be little jerry garcias and they're
all going to be like yeah man like i'm
totally for it yeah i think the fear of
psychedelics is that it can make people
so radical that they'll flip the system
on its head but the system is breaking
so hard right now that we need to shake
it and people will see there is money
involved we can fix our economy with
with creativity i got an idea for like a
short film yeah where it's like a dude
who does dmt and they say you blast off
right you like perceive another
dimension or something yeah but you're
still tethered to your body so you like
come out of your body and use other
dimension but then you snap back once it
wears off right but then eventually when
he's blasting off
he's like something happens as an
earthquake or whatever and like his
house falls down and he dies
separating himself from his body and now
he's trapped in like the machine elf
world because there's no way to go back
because normally when you die like your
body is there and it doesn't go there
but now you're here and then when you're
trapped thanks for checking out this
clip from timcast irl come hang out live
monday through friday at 8 pm eastern
time super chat we'll even answer some
of your questions if you want to check
out the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time